[Music]
perversion VDOT only on our hair go upon
[Music]
Severson
[Music]
you did one
[Music]
Oh
hospitable people
ha
she was so
Oh
one of the things for simple now where
we were when we were I was start to
because Gateway and start to get built
slowly and and actually the work it
really is there is no person in the work
you don't see the work its kind of get
really invisible does it mean the work
it really is the person who inhabit the
world this mean without the people on
the worker there's nothing to see almost
this is a model of k21
and as yes you can see that our here
there is only one lady but usually is
yet it should be I think so ten or
fifteen or twenty people we are trying
to see how many people might be able to
have access to the 2d surfaces which
somehow you know it's kind of a weave
space together this kind of a early
modern we have been trying now allocate
twenty one for example is a you know if
you move here somebody else also is
moving pretty much over there and there
is this kind of a codependency of
movement which is something which
interest me and at the same time way
what is and also it is secret it's like
when you walk here that the net you get
very transparent and you see down here
twenty four twenty eight meters down the
space this mean it also like a kind of
maybe connect also people from below
which are in the Piazza they start to
see what's going on up there and then
you can weave different connections
around the building
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you